statistiquement c'est frappes ont lieu
toutes les deux semaines pourquoi deux
semaines parce que il faut à peu près
deux semaines pour pouvoir d'une part
produire un certain nombre de missiles
supplémentaires parce que les stocks
sont en voie de disparition si vous
voulez et puis deuxièmement il faut
beaucoup de temps pour tout l'appareil
militaire russe qui va du renseignement
l'analyse des imageries satellites etc
pour pouvoir
planifier préparer
réaliser en fait toutes ces opérations
de ciblage donc en fait toutes les deux
semaines il y a des frappes entre 400 et
800 missiles qui sont pardon entre 40 et
86 qui sont tirés et qui frappent les
infrastructures critiques de toutes
l'Ukraine est-ce que cette stratégie de
désorganisation
est efficace sur le plan militaire
non elle est pas efficace d'une part
parce qu'elle ne cible pas véritablement
les ressources qui pourraient
véritablement affaiblir l'armée
ukrainienne je pense au pont je pense au
dépôt aussi bien de carburant les dépôts
de maintenance etc même les centres
d'instruction de l'armée
ukrainienne ne sont pas véritablement
visés ni même d'ailleurs certaines de
ses usines qui fabriquent encore du
matériel de guerre donc non on vise les
infrastructures critiques civiles et
puis l'objectif est clairement politique
et a pour volonté en fait une pression
sur l'opinion publique de d'arrêter la
guerre et est-ce que ces stocks ont pu
être alimentés
par des approvisionnements qui venaient
de Chine
probablement pas parce que les missiles
chinois pour je dirais depuis les le
milieu des années 60 ou la fin des
années 1960 n'est pas véritablement
compatible donc c'est assez difficile de
l'imaginer maintenant encore une fois
puisque on parle de bricolage on peut
tout à fait imaginer qu'on utilise je
crois qu'il a été retrouvé des logiciels
et puis certaines pièces qui proviennent
de machines à laver ou de
d'électroménager qui ont été utilisés
par l'industrie russe pour pour adapter
ou pour modifier un certain nombre
d'engins